you know so why this hashtag of course
the hashtag stay work but I love it
because in a way it's um it's gonna
believe them phrases that take a very
complex concept and that makes that
accessible to a large public because
they work is a way to talk about
critical consciousness and what you what
we've seen say in the past elections is
this increase of current code fitness
and one thing which have been trying to
share with the student is that this this
concept of fitness isn't at all a new
phenomenon so in fact if you look at the
way history is taught in the US if you
look at see Howard Zinn's book about
history it tells us how our history
books are filled with fake news so the
point is that it's not just fake news
that's fake and and what the students
get to see through for example the
Haitian Revolution is that in the
textbooks most of them actually almost
all of them maybe except for one or two
they got to learn lots of details about
the French Revolution and then the
American Revolution you don't know all
these about that but almost none of them
knew about Haiti but if you think of
what evolution means the evolution has
been has had much more impact when it
comes to human rights civil liberties
than both the u.s. Revolution and the
French one and the question that I asked
them is why is it that they went through
the the elementary school the high
school some of them most of the college
years without ever hearing about the
Haitian Revolution right which in fact
has has been much more potent than both
the French one and the u.s. one and to
me that that was a great way to
introduced to them the idea that you
have to stay work you have to understand
why history is being taught in such a
bad way that excludes the one revolution
that actually allowed this concept of
equality among all human beings to
become true because both in France and
in the u.s. when they were claiming
liberty equality fraternity they were
still people who were in Chains you know
in fact blacks were still in in in in
slavery women couldn't vote it's only in
Haiti that revolution took its real
meaning in really changing the world
order in creating this possibility for
all human beings to be equal but yet
it's not taught in the classroom in the
US and to me that's one of the most
blatant case of thick news that's become
so much part of the way children are
educated in the u.s. so stair walk means
to be alert to this kind of propaganda
that that passes for history that's they
work and of course we look at other
examples where they themselves
participate in these areas of knowledge
actually subserve hierarchies of power
that's that stay work